porque la reina isabel segunda toma esta
decisión en estos momentos de alguna
manera influye que este sea su año de
jubileo de platino
sí exactamente valentín a la reina
cumple 96 años y 70 en el trono quiere
evitar los escándalos y este es un
escándalo bastante grave con lo cual se
le retiran los títulos al príncipe
andrés seguirá siendo príncipe pero no
alteza real seguirá siendo conde de ahí
veneci varón de cada día pero no duque
de york y sus hijas beatriz y eugenia no
serán herederas al título de duquesa de
york a no ser que la reina les otorgue
el título y el tratamiento de antes a
reales de igual manera la antigua esposa
del príncipe andrés sarah ferguson a
quien por acuerdo de divorcio se le
seguía denominando la duquesa de york
también perderá ese tipo bueno usted ya
lo estaba mencionando que otros efectos
prácticos tiene que se retiren estos
títulos y a qué se refiere el palacio de
bukingham con quitarlos datos reales
pues precisamente valentín a los
patronatos reales corresponden a la
presidencia de varias fundaciones
tanto la reina como sus parientes
cercanos dentro de ellos el duque de
gloucester el duque de que en la
princesa alejandra y el príncipe miguel
de kent presiden algunas fundaciones
debido a que son muchísimas las que
hacen parte de la commonwealth y la
reina no puede junto con sus hijos
presidir las todas de esta manera la
reina guardará la preeminencia de
algunas de las instituciones otras
corresponderán al príncipe de gales a la
duquesa de cornualles al duque de
cambridge sale duquesa de cambridge a la
al conde de wessex su hijo menor y a la
princesa real ana quienes entonces
tendrán que asumir algunas funciones
adicionales ya que desde 2019 el
príncipe andrés en este caso podríamos
hablar de su alteza serenísima el
príncipe andrés ya no su empresa real
pues ha sido retirado de las funciones
en torno a la representatividad dentro
de la casa real inglesa bueno y como
queda la casa real con este escándalo se
ve afectada en reino unido
claro que se ve afectada sin embargo el
orden de sucesión pues se modifica
igualmente porque después de la reina
sigue el príncipe de gales el duque de
cambridge el príncipe jorge de cambridge
carlota de cambridge louis de cambridge
después seguirían la princesa beatriz y
la princesa eugenia hijas del duque de
york el conde de wessex lady luisa y el
vizconde sever y después la princesa
real ana entonces se restringe
prácticamente en 23 niveles el orden
sucesor al en la casa real precisamente
también por el retiro de las funciones
del duque de esos ex